Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
So today's Maestro Hook,...
...a good conversation piece you can use with foreigners is about food.
So in a cafeteria,...
...when you take a Westerner out to dinner or when a foreigner comes...
...and you wanna take them out to good food,...
...there's a little few things you might wanna worry about.
Western people aren't really comfortable with putting all your chopsticks into one dish,...
...so maybe you wanna avoid something like a Japanese nabe.
You wanna make sure that you can eat each piece and don't get so involved with using chopsticks together.
And also, when you say "raw food" like "raw sushi" or "raw fish",...
...the word "raw" in English sounds very strong and it sounds very, very raw.
So, don't use the word "raw"...
...and use the word "fresh" like "fresh fish" or "fresh vegetables".
Not raw vegetables, okay?
Alright.
So, Maestro Menu.
I like...
I'm a big fan of...
I'm a big fan of sukiyaki.
I'm a big fan of boiled food.
I hate...
I don't like...
I'm not so crazy about sushi.
I'm not so crazy about sukiyaki.
I'm not a big fan of sushi.
I'm crazy about chocolate.
So...
Okay, Maestro Lines.
Would you like some tofu?
Oh! You know what, I'm not so crazy about tofu.
Oh! Okay. No problem.
Would you like some half-boiled eggs?
Oh! I'm crazy about eggs.
I'm a big fan of eggs.
Alright.
So when you're eating, make sure you have a lot of expressions 'cause eating is fun.
So, see you next week again on Native Maestro...
...and there's more English to help you become the native maestro.
Bye-bye!